who may be at risk for severe
complications of covin 19 due to age or
underlying medical conditions we must
also lessen the burden of cotan 19 among
racial and ethnic groups
disproportionately impacted CDC
continues to improve its data collection
of comprehensive data of each case race
and ethnicity from our state local
tribal and territorial partners
reporting from hospital surveillance
sites for example of increased
incompleteness on race and ethnicity
from 30 percent to now more than 80
percent CDC is also receiving more
complete data from our Public Health
Partners the recent CDC study examined
more than 1.3 million kovat 19 cases
found that the most underlying health
conditions were cardiovascular diabetes
obesity and chronic lung disease
hospitalizations were six times higher
for these individuals and death twelve
times higher those reporting these
conditions compared to those without CDC
is working to ensure the equity and
health outcomes and the social
determinants are being addressed through
the Cova 19 response CDC continues to
provide communities with technical
expertise tools and information to
confront the virus CDC's Creed created
more than 1500 specialized resource and
guidance documents would have been
consulted more than 1.5 billion times on
the CDC website we've deployed over
5,000 personnel and must make real-time
decisions based on real-time data data
is the backbone of any disease threat
response with the resources that
Congress has provided data modernization
is underway we also must ensure that our
laboratories have resilience advanced
technology personnel expertise and
supplies are being sourced our public
health workforce must grow exponentially
to address kovin 19 in future public
health threats thousands of contact
tracers are on board and being recruited
by public health departments across our
nation
bottom line sustained investment in the
public health system is an investment in
the health and prosperity of our nation
last CDC has begun to bear
or months ahead when the next season's
influenza illness will occur
simultaneously potentially with kovat 19
increasing the challenges on hospitals
healthcare courage the American people
to be prepared and to embrace flu
vaccination with confidence for yourself
your families in the communities this
single act will save lives thank you and
I look forward to your questions thank
you very much mr. chairman ranking
member Walt and the force is to develop
safe and effective vaccines speaking of
the first fundamental knowledge of the
virus and what the virus is capable of
doing we've done a number of studies now
that had informed how we're approaching
therapeutics and vaccines for example
the precise molecular structure of the
spike protein which is that part of the
virus which actually gives it its name
coronavirus because of these spikes that
stick out from the virus that is the way
the virus binds to cells in the body
this has been precisely delineated by
NIH scientists and those that we fund
second the demonstration of the precise
receptor whereby the virus binds to
cells in the body allowing it to enter
and cause disease in addition we develop
animal models we do Natural History
studies such as understanding the virus
in different demographic groups second
is the development of diagnostics and
assays we need and we will get within a
reasonable period of time based on a
major investment in the radix protein
program Diagnostics that are
point-of-care simple precise sensitive
and specific we hope by the end of the
fall and into the early winter we will
have these for wide distribution third
the development and characterization of
drugs you've all heard the first
successful randomized placebo-controlled
trial of a drug called REM de Sevilla
which was used in hospitalized patients
with lung disease it showed a
statistically significant
but modest impact on decreasing the time
to release from the hospital namely
faster recovery in addition this drug is
now being used in combination with
another drug that blocks the
inflammatory response virus in imide we
are also looking at a variety of others
convalescent plasma hyper immune
globulin other drugs monoclonal
antibodies as well as other immune based
therapies fourth the development of safe
and effective vaccines the hallmark of
all really defining responses that we
have to virus diseases if you look at
the history of viral diseases it is
generally vaccines that put the nail in
the coffin of these types we are now
mounting a major effort in which we're
collaborating with industry and
public-private partnerships to get
vaccine trials that are developed that
harmonize with each other in other words
to have multiple trials in which we have
common questions that are being asked
common laboratories that are being
looked at common data and safety
monitoring board and common primary
secondary and tertiary endpoints so that
the data can be compared from one to
another you have probably heard that one
of those vaccines and there are more
than one there are several that are
moving along at various paces one of
them will enter phase 3 study in July
this is one that is already shown in
preliminary studies some very favorable
response in the animal models that were
developed there will be others that will
follow one month two months three months
later although you can never guarantee
at all the safety and efficacy of a
vaccine until you actually test it in
the field we feel cautiously optimistic
based on the concerted effort and the
fact that we are taking financial risks
not risks to safety not risk to the
integrity of the science but financial
risks to be able to be ahead of the game
so that when and I believe it will be
when and not if we get favorable
candidates with good results
we'll be able to make them available to
the American public as I said to this
committee months ago within a year from
when we started which would put us at
the end of this calendar year and the
beginning of 2021 I'll stop there mr.
chairman and be happy to answer
questions later thank you thank you dr.
Fauci and thanks for all your
contributions to fighting this pandemic
and I'll say the same about Admiral
girar who I bother the most you're
recognized for five minutes Admiral
Thank You chairman pallone and I always
enjoy our conversation you call me any
time ranking member Wald and
distinguished members of the Committee
on March 12th secretary azar requested
that I lead the coordination of kovat 19
testing efforts within the Department of
Health and Human Services and I would
like to be clear that although I am no
longer full-time deployed to FEMA I am
maintaining my role coordinating testing
to date the nation has performed over
twenty seven million kovat 19 tests now
averaging about 500,000 tests per day
even without any major technical
advances I estimate the nation will have
the capacity to perform between 40 to 50
million tests per month I fall to
address the public health challenges
over the past months we implemented a
phased approach to meet the testing
needs at each stage of the pandemic
especially now during reopening when the
need for testing is the greatest in
early March HHS and FEMA developed and
implemented 41 community-based
drive-through testing sites in locations
prioritized by the CDC in collaboration
with our state and local partners these
sites have tested nearly 300,000
high-risk individuals and served as
prototypes that have been duplicated
multifold next we leverage trusted
pharmacies to further implement
community testing especially for
minorities and underserved this federal
program is now providing testing at 611
locations in 47 states in the district
70% of which are in communities with
moderate to high social vulnerability
this program has tested over six hundred
and eighty eight thousand individuals
federally qualified health centers serve
over 20
9 million people across the nation they
provide care to one in five of those
uninsured one in five rural Americans
one in three living in poverty and 1.3
million homeless again to assure we
reach these most vulnerable among us 93%
of FQHCs offer coded 19 testing to
further expand access we authorized all
licensed pharmacists to order and
administer kovat 19 testing under the
public readiness and emergency
preparedness tour prep act over 90% of
Americans live within 5 miles of a
pharmacy again assuring widespread
availability on June 4th using
authorities provided to the secretary
under cares HHS released new mandatory
laboratory reporting guidance so that we
can confirm that all groups are
benefitting equitably from kovat 19
testing lab reports must include
demographic information like race
ethnicity age and gender and today I am
pleased to announce the selection of
Morehouse School of Medicine as the
awardee for a new forty million dollar
initiative to fight kovat 19 among
racial and ethnic minorities as well as
rural and other socially vulnerable
communities this cooperative agreement
with the office of the assistant
secretary for health office of minority
health and Morehouse School of Medicine
will develop and implement a strategic
network of national state territorial
tribal and local organizations to
deliver kovat 19 related information to
communities hardest hit by the pandemic
in the first year of this agreement
Morehouse School of Medicine will
receive 15 million dollars this massive
expansion of testing resulted in
unprecedented demand for supplies
reagents in laboratory platforms to meet
this demand we secured the global supply
chain through a military air bridge we
work directly with manufacturers to
increase domestic production we
collaborated with external partners to
validate new technologies we secured and
prioritize scarce point-of-care tests
for state Public Health laboratories the
Indian Health Service and other critical
needs finally we use title three of the
defense production act
to further invest in domestic
manufacturing these actions and others
have enabled our current efforts with
States territories and tribes to
implement evidence-based diagnostic and
surveillance plans I would like to close
by recognizing my fellow officers in the
United States Public Health Service
commissioned Corps the uniformed service
that I lead four thousand four hundred
eighty two officers have deployed to
support the pandemic response including
to the Diamond Princess cruise ship in
Japan to our military bases repatriating
Americans to our community-based testing
sites to FEMA and Task Forces directly
inside nursing homes and to field
hospitals across our nation exemplifying
the care and compassion that all of us
feel for those who have suffered during
this pandemic I thank each and every one
of these officers and their families and
on their behalf I would like to thank
all of you in Congress for supporting
our training needs and the establishment
of a Ready Reserve Corps to supplement
our ranks during inevitable future
national emergencies thank you again for
the opportunity to provide these remarks
thank you I Rowland thank you for
mentioning the both military and
civilians who are out front in helping
us during this crisis that really
appreciate all that they do and we have
to make sure that we help them as much
as possible so last but certainly not
least because the FDA is just as
important is dr. Hahn or Commissioner
Hahn sir chair monville Owen ranking
member Walden and distinguished members
of the committee thank you for inviting
me here today first like to start by
thanking all of you for your support
of the agency and US government with the
laws that you've passed and become law
of the land it has helped a great deal
in our response FDA has a critical role
in the federal government's response to
the Cova 19 pandemic we remain focused
on our mission of protecting and
promoting the health and safety of
Americans President Trump has requested
and we have provided appropriate
regulatory flexibilities to assure that
the American public have access to
critical medical products safe foods and
a confidence that the government is
taking measures to
important public health issues FDA has
used our emergency authorities since the
beginning of this pandemic we have
issued more than a hundred emergency use
authorization for Diagnostics personal
protective equipment ventilators and
other devices as well as for drug
products since the public health
emergency was declared we issued more
than 50 guidance documents to help
ensure the continuity of health care and
safe food supply and we put into place
new initiatives to accelerate the
development of needed products
additionally we have kept the American
public up to date on what they need to
do to protect themselves and to contain
the virus from spreading we are now
preparing for the next phase of
addressing this evolving crisis it is
mission-critical that the agency
continue to be diligent assuring the
safety of the products that we regulate
and that we also put in place processes
needed to assure the protections that
the public will need there are a number
of experiences we have gained over the
past few months that will inform our
plans
we recognize that we must be bold in our
decision-making and advance effective
solutions to achieve challenging public
health objectives therefore we have
begun a comprehensive real-time review
and assessment of our actions to date to
address the Cova 19 pandemic the
objective is to identify and address
potential organizational and
programmatic changes that should be
implemented without delay to advance the
ongoing response to Coba 19 we need to
assure that we leverage what is working
well while at the same time review our
framework and policies to be
commissioned to effectively identify and
respond to quickly evolving public
health situations a major focus of this
effort will be to identify what
regulatory policies should be continued
and accelerated consistent with
executive order 13 24 signed by the
president durable policy organizational
and programmatic changes will be
consistent with advancing the agency's
public health mission and will inform
our strategic priorities moving forward
one of the challenges facing FDA during
the Cova 19 PM
is how to assure the timely review of
medical product applications despite an
incredible surge in volume and
constraints on our ability to conduct in
site inspections I'm a pleased to
announce today that FDA has maintained
the same pace of meeting its goals on
applications for medical products for
the last six months that has maintained
in recent years we are on target to meet
our user fee goals for the drugs this
year by reviewing and taking timely
action on at least 90% of brand generic
and biosimilar drug applications even
during the pandemic additionally this
work has continued at a time when the
number of applications received in some
centers is substantially higher than the
pre COBIT 19 times I want to thank the
more than 17,000 employees of T of the
FDA for their incredible efforts one
that reflects the remarkable dedication
and commitment to the public health of
all Americans finally I'd like to
discuss with the top of mind for all
Americans namely the work that FDA is
doing to facilitate the development of
safe vaccines and therapeutics FDA
launched emergency review and
development program called the corona
virus treatment accelerated program or C
tap and we continue to work night and
day to provide guidance and to review
proposals from companies scientists and
researchers who are developing therapies
let me be clear that data and science
will dictate when we will have safe and
effective treatments and vaccines for
kovat 19 as dr. Fauci just mentioned
toward that end FDA is using every
available authority and applying every
appropriate regulatory flexibility to
facilitate development and testing we
have not lost sight of our solemn
responsibility to the American people to
ensure our decisions related to all
medical products are based on science
and data and that is a commitment that
the American public can have confidence
in again I assure you that the FDA will
provide leadership expertise guidance
information and whatever else is needed
as we continue to address this
unprecedented challenge thank you and I
look forward to your questions Thank You
Commissioner Han that concludes our
openings from the witnesses and so now
we'll move to member questions each
member will have five minutes to ask
questions of our witness
and I'll start by recognizing myself for
five minutes
now you know that I'm very critical of
the president for a lack of leadership
from the start of this pandemic which I
think continues and of course is
difficult because you work in theory for
the president and I feel that many of
you on many occasions actually wanted to
take more leadership and be as as dr.
hon mention or Commissioner Hahn fully
cognizant of the data and the science so
it's difficult because I'm going to
issue questions about the president's
lack of leadership and I know it's hard
for you to answer those so we'll see but
I do believe the president is
encouraging behaviors that are not
consistent with good public health such
as encouraging thousands to attend a
rally and not mandate the wearing of
masks and I can't imagine that NIH or
CDC would suggest this is the best
practice in the face of this pandemic so
it's sort of like there's two versions
of reality here one's the president's
and one's hopefully yours based on data
and science but I want to hear from the
experts so let me start with dr. Fowler
you are a trusted voice and have always
been candid with us in the American
public give us an unvarnished view of
where we are at our fight against kovat
19 is quickly if you can thank you very
much for that question mr. chairman it
really is a mixed bag we have a very
large country very heterogeneous major
differences for example between the New
York metropolitan area and Casper
Wyoming if you look at how we've been
hit we've been hit badly I mean anybody
who looks at the numbers we've had now
over 120,000 deaths and we've had two
and a half million infections so it's a
serious situation in some respects we've
done very well right now for example the
New York metropolitan area which has
been hit extraordinarily hard has done
very well in bringing the cases down and
using the guidelines that we have very
carefully put together in a stepwise
fashion to try and carefully reopen
their city and their state however in
other areas of the country
now seeing a disturbing surge of
infections that looks like it's a
combination but one of the things is an
increase in community spread and that's
something that I'm really quite
concerned about that and you know that
this has been something that's been in
the press over the past couple of days
we were going down from thirty thousand
to twenty five to twenty and now we sort
of state about flat and now we're going
up a couple of days ago there were
thirty thousand new infections
that's very troublesome to me the way
you address that and I've said this over
and over again is you have to have the
manpower the system the testing to
identify isolate and contact trace in an
effective way so that when you see those
increases you can understand where
they're coming from and you can do
something about them right now the next
couple of weeks are going to be critical
in our ability to address those surgeons
that we're seeing in Florida in Texas in
Arizona and in other states they're not
the only ones that are having a
difficulty bottom line mr. chairman it's
a mixed bag some good and some now we
have a problem with all right now I'm
gonna have to ask about the president
because you talked about testing and how
important it is and I you know
everyone's roar and I know how important
it is that is rally over the weekend the
president said and I quote when you do
testing to that extent you're going to
find more people you're going to find
more cases so I said to my people slow
the testing down please unquote and this
morning he said he meant this so doctor
foul sure do you agree with that does it
make sense that to safely open our
economy we should be limiting the number
of tests rather than ensuring that
anyone who needs a test can get one and
you don't have to mention the president
I did but tell us about the testing and
your microphone is on I as a member of
the task force and my colleagues on the
task force to my knowledge I know for
sure but to my knowledge none of us have
ever been told to slow down on testing
that just is a fact in fact we will be
doing more
as you've heard from Admiral Jarrah not
only testing to specifically identify
people in the identify isolating contact
trace but also much more surveillance if
you want to get your arms around and
understand exactly what's going on in
community spread so it's the opposite
we're gonna be doing more testing not
less and then let me just ask the same
question of dr. Redfield do you agree
with the President on this do you think
we should be testing more people you
don't want to talk about the president
just tell us if you think we should be
testing more people
yes dr. Thatcher said all of us have
been and continue to be committed to
increasing readily timely access to
testing we've made a marked improvement
we still have a ways to go one of the
key things as Tony mentioned is
surveillance expanding surveillance
because of the asymptomatic nature of
this infection and in doing so we're
looking at ways that can really
substantially enhance testing by
potentially pulling samples so right now
as Gerard said we're doing five hundred
thousand six hundred thousand tests a
day if we can pull samples five to one
that would bring it to three million
tests a day so we're continuing to try
to enhance testing it's a critical
underpinning of our response
thank you dr. Redfield I recognize a mr.
Walden now for five minutes
Thank You mr. chairman let me let me go
straight to the question that my
colleague gasps I'll just ask each of
you for a yes or no answer as president
Trump ever directed you to slow down
testing for Co vid 19 in the United
States dr. Redfield no no sir no
congressman thank you all right let's go
to some other issues here dr. Han you
created a website I believe on the FDA
site dealing with convalescent Plaza
plasma and antibody rich investigational
therapies that may help fight the virus
what's the status of the research into
the effectiveness of convalescent Plaza
in fighting kovat 19 what do we know
right now Thank You congressman Walden a
really important question from a
therapeutics point of view as everyone
here knows a convalescent plasma is
where you take the nach
from a person who's recovered from covin
19 those antibodies and then
administered to a person who's sick so
we have partnered with Barda and HHS as
well as the Mayo Clinic to development
what's called an expanded access program
we have safety data from over 20,000
patients that shows this is a very safe
therapy and our preliminary assessment
of the effectiveness of this plasma is
quite encouraging we continue to look at
the information if those data hold we
will have potentially another weapon in
the armamentarium against Cova 19
pending those final results this will
also allow us to have information that
will feed the development of monoclonal
antibodies and something else called a
hyper immune globulin which we can pool
that plasma and actually give it as an
injection to people so I think it's a
it's a good news story right now we have
to wait for the final data to come in
and we should know very shortly about
that there are also several randomized
trials looking at this as well that are
ongoing across the country alright thank
you very much dr. Redfield CDC has
developed a new test to simultaneously
detect two strains of influenza and the
kovat 19 and is seeking an emergency use
Authority how does the CDC envision its
combined test to be used yeah I think
it's very important as I mentioned as we
get to the fall we're gonna have
influenza and kovat at the same time and
CDC's develop developing that test for
the public health system but in parallel
the private sector now is also advantage
got advanced development maybe dr. Han
months comment on similar tests in the
private sector so to facilitate timely
diagnosis of these two Co circulating
pathogens dr. Ahn do you want to comment
on that yes our cooperation was emerald
raw we we have been working with
companies to actually look at that
emerald raw has been at the forefront of
this it's been a great battle I just
agree with my colleagues we're all
concerned about the possibility of Co
circulation of influenza A and B as well
as kovat 19 when it comes to flu season
so we want to do everything we can to
simplify the diagnosis and you can have
if you have a single test and
working with multiple manufacturers as
as usual the CDC is usually in the lead
but their multiple manufacturers both
that point of care in laboratory who
will have this type of test available
right excellent you all have been
subject to a lot of criticism as has the
president often that's leveled after we
know facts we didn't know at the time
when things started and so it's really
great if you have hindsight in 20/20
vision you could look back and say
should have done that then I want to
look forward what is it you need from
Congress that you do not have now to
have America ready for the fall what
should we be preparing for now for the
fall I don't care who wants to start
that I'm down to a minute to answer so
dr. Redfield
I think first I want to just express our
appreciation to Congress for the
supplemental funding I think it's of
note that CDC has been able already to
disperse 12 billion dollars to the
states to help prepare their kovat
responses and really that's an
unprecedent amount of resources I would
only ask that we look to how to make
this a sustainable investment as opposed
to a sporadic investment to this
particular challenge we have right now
all right
dr. pouchy what do we need to worry
about what don't you have well I just to
reiterate what what dr. Redfield said we
are extraordinarily grateful for the you
know the unprecedented amount of
supplementary funding that the Congress
gave to us which really make it totally
possible for us to do the kinds of
things we need to do on an emergency
basis but again to mention what dr.
Redfield said we have to establish some
corporate memory I said to this
committee literally many times over the
many years that we forget things when we
get distant from them we're going
through a terrible ordeal right now we
need to have in place the stable type of
support for preparedness for outbreaks
we will get through this this will end
hopefully sooner rather than later but
we need to establish a system so that we
are prepared for future outbreaks Thank
You mr. chair could the other two just
answer that
question quickly Admiral what do you
need you don't have what should we be
worrying about I want to express my
thanks again to our committee but let me
get to to the points I think
sustainability and commitment is very
important I was involved in Ebola in
2015 in Dallas trying to lead some of
the policy options during that time and
you see over a five-year period we sort
of forgot all the lessons that we were
trying to get implemented including PPE
and other stockpiles I would say some of
the biggest limitations and I know
everyone is working on this is the
national data infrastructure we need
when we started out I'm calling up 100
hospitals a day trying to understand
who's on an ICU bed who's not who has a
ventilator how much you have left and we
got through this early not by systems
but by people working 24/7 the third
thing is I'm just going to pound at the
vaccine infrastructure in this country
to promote vaccinations to promote
vaccine confidence to make sure that
people have the right information about
safety and efficacy that we order enough
flu vaccine because we really need to
get everybody vaccinated this winter one
thing that minimizes our problems if we
get everybody flu vaccine that's one
less virus that could kill twenty thirty
fifty thousand 70,000 and potentially
even be a co-infection with kovat dr.
hog yeah thank you again thank you for
the support one big point I want to make
here is that what we've learned during
this epidemic is what Admiral draw said
is that we have an Access to Information
issue we have learned that we need to
collect real-world evidence in real-time
during an emergency just like a doctor
would do during an emergency to inform
decisions and how we could change them
moving forward so your support for
real-world evidence generation would be
incredibly helpful so now we're gonna
move to our members based on seniority
and I think our next few are our virtual
so just remind you to mute if you don't
do so on your own I'll just keep
reminding you so next we have mr. rush
from Illinois I want to thank you
missing
[Music]
communities are suffering more than
banks meaning oh I think I know what to
I didn't hear it quite as clear as I
want but I think I know what the
congressman is referring to so when
you're looking at the african-american
community and them the minority
community in general as a demographic
group there are two elements that make
it much more difficult for them and why
they're suffering disproportionately one
is the risk of infection because of
economic and other considerations the
jobs that the majority of them would
find themselves in does not allow them
to protect themselves by looking into a
computer and doing telework most of them
are essential on outside having to
mingle in a society in which the virus
is circulating so right at the get-go
they have a greater risk of getting
infected and then we know from a lot of
experience now
at the situation regarding whether or
not you have serious consequences
hospitalizations intubation
complications and death relate very
strongly to the prevalence and incidence
of underlying comorbid conditions which
are clearly disproportionately more
expressed in the african-american
population than in the rest of the
population and that particularly
includes hypertension diabetes obesity
chronic lung disease and kidney disease
so unfortunately we have a situation
where it's sort of a double whammy of a
negative capability of them to respond
through no fault of their own because of
underlying conditions and the conditions
in which they find themselves with
infants community nursing Germans -
knees curl or anything I think the
question was what I consider
institutional racism as contributing no
I don't think that's yes yes thank you
congressman well I mean obviously the
african-american community has suffered
from racism for a very very long period
of time and I cannot imagine that that
has not contributed to the conditions
that they find themselves in
economically and otherwise so the answer
congressman is yes as you go to the
Morehouse College of Medicine content
tracing and stitching I have introduced
a little the tracer which comes from 100
million dollars for testing and tracing
we've been singing around your mouth I
know
tracing and attention Thank You
congressman for testing and contact
tracing
we're gonna need billions of dollars I
mean that's the amounts of investment
that we're doing partially through CDC
this specific award is to have Morehouse
lead a consortium of organizations like
100 black men who do DOS you asked the
National Association of community health
workers the National Council of urban
Indian Health etc etc to really focus on
the specific educational testing and
linkage to care needs of underserved
minorities and some of those also in the
rural population my personal opinion is
forty million dollars as a start it's
going to need to be a lot more than that
in order to reach the people that we
need to reach Thank You Bobby
Thank You Admiral next is mr. Upton from
Michigan thanks thanks very much mr.
chairman really appreciate the testimony
that we've heard thus far and the
interaction that we'll have between all
of our eye
I guess the first question I got you
good friend thank you for your service
for sure
in recent weeks of course you made the
statement many as a hundred million
doses of vaccine before the year I've
heard from a number of companies just in
recent days after the Pfizer hope that
perhaps a billion doses for the end of
your calendar year 21 so as they move
through these new process or maybe even
get into some production a little bit
like their body by not approvals yet
worthy
the promise of the marketplace and
really saving the world let's face it
what you thought as to how early we may
see an EU a an emergency use
authorization approved for any of these
vaccines based on what you know today
and under scenarios that we may see
something in the next number of months
in terms of an approval lay out what you
think is a real distinct possibility
where we might end up being okay thank
you I didn't hear on it well I didn't
hear everything you said but I think I
got enough of it to answer your question
at least the last part but I think is
very important and I welcome the
opportunity to address this the idea
about the doses that would be available
you know a couple of hundred million
doses in the beginning of the year some
companies saying that in a couple of
years a year it's you'll have as many as
a billion doses I think that's real most
people would raise their eyebrows and
think that how is that gonna happen and
it is because things are being done at
risk people companies are starting to
plan to make doses even before you know
the vaccine works so the risk of the
speed is not risk to safety it's not
risk to scientific integrity it's risk
to money so put that aside the point
that that congressman Upton made I think
it's very important we need to be
careful that we don't jump because of
our need to get vaccines for those who
need it that we do not definitively
prove safety and efficacy before we make
decisions about distribution we've heard
a lot about emergency use authorization
an emergency use authorization is
important but it has to be done in a
situation where you fulfill the criteria
for the emergency use authorization I
would be very disappointed if we jumped
to a conclusion before we knew that a
vaccine was truly safe and truly
effective because I wouldn't want the
perpetual ambiguity
of not knowing whether or not it is
truly safe and truly affect him that's
the reason why we're doing several
randomized placebo-controlled trials
with power enough that could give us
that answer I hope that answers your
question Fred under the best scenario
that we might see a new a issues like
you all along with I guess would
actually be the FDA right the issue that
that yes the answer is yes let me just
quickly answer that and hand it over to
to Steve because he may want to answer
that we're going into the first phase
one phase three efficacy trial in July
it takes at least a month to get to the
second dose because it's a prime boost
you'll take another couple of months to
accrue or enroll enough people that if
there is viral activity in the community
and we have our sites not only in the
United States but all over the world in
Brazil and in South Africa so if we get
an efficacy signal you're gonna get an
efficacy signal more quickly the more
cases there are now if it turns out that
they're not a lot of cases that may take
longer and that's the reason why you
can't give an accurate prediction of
when you're gonna get those data Steve
you want to take it from here yeah
thanks dr. Falchi so just a couple of
issues to your point congressman Upton
one is we are um we are working with
sponsors across the board private
industry operation warp-speed
etc those who are developing vaccines
and we're providing technical assistance
regarding clinical trial design the
number of participants in the clinical
trials as well as the endpoints that we
want to see to make an adjudication
about safety and effectiveness and I
want to emphasize what dr. Fauci said
and that is the the acceleration is
really around taking financial risk
around the development process the
acceleration is not cutting corners with
respect to the assessment of safety and
effectiveness the American people can
rely
the fact that FDA has many experts in
the vaccine area we've been doing this
for years and we will rely upon the
science and data when it's available to
us to make that adjudication and
decision regarding an EU a I cannot
prejudge when that will happen
Thank you Thank You Fred next we have
the gentlewoman from California miss su
Thank You mr. chairman and morning
everybody
I'd like to start with dr. dr. we had a
conversation in the week and I expressed
you really my thing my appointment about
as a threat the most prestigious
institution in the world diseases
prevention the United States today is
number one in the world in sections and
invest anything anything can be American
people are in pain they're good there's
a great deal in communities there's
confusion because for many reasons and I
urged you as head of CDC to speak
directly to the American people I know
the agencies are talking to each other
I consider that a whisper because the
American people are not hearing you
speak out they deserve to hear the truth
we have heard dr. Falchi time and time
again putting out trusted information to
the American people the American people
are divided on this issue of the of the
virus imagine that so I continue to urge
you to speak out your doctor put your
white
jacket on and speak weakly to the
American people they want to know what's
coming what is ahead my constituents
asked me on a consistent basis what's
next what is our government doing that's
a haunting question and so while we're
doing the nice back and forth this
morning good questions on the part of
members I really remain dismayed and
deeply disappointed we need leadership
coming out of the CDC real leadership it
was an outrage that there was a
gathering in Tulsa six of the
president's and maintenance people were
infected and it's my understanding the
two Secret Service agents were how can
the CDC allow this this pandemic this
virus to be something political you have
to push back you're a scientist you're a
doctor now to dr. Hahn I'm sure you've
read the several articles regarding
hydroxychloroquine every study states it
doesn't work in any setting in fact it
has known side effects a cardiac issues
being one so there's a danger in terms
of the side effects as commissioner you
see all the data are you going to inform
the American people doctors across the
country about these facts Thank You
congresswoman for that question and
indeed we are I can refer the the
committee to several documents that we
have put out over the last several weeks
regarding hydroxychloroquine with
respect to the issues we issued a Safety
Alert particularly around the
combination of contracted chloroquine
with and other drugs that might affect
the heart and as you know we've taken
recent recent action regarding you
specifically and directly to the
American people so isn't
there's teach in how to drop yeah Clark
yes ma'am there is an FDA voices piece
that's authored by me as well as a piece
that's directly to the American people
about the status of hydrogen's work I
want to know if you have speak and
spoken out verbally to the American
people to doctors across the country
III don't people here paper with all due
respect yes ma'am and I appreciate the
question but every opportunity I've had
to be in the media I've been asked that
question and I have communicated that
same information about the current
question dr. Hahn there have been
several articles expressing concerns
political press being placed FDA by the
state unequivocably any political
pressure is applied to you and they see
a report back to this committee I I will
certainly unequivocally state that if I
receive political pressure I will report
this committee I can tell you that I
have not felt political pressure nor has
the FDA to make any decision in any
specific direction
thank you it's about a direct political
pressure so thank you responsible back
thank you mr. Shue next is mr. Lauda
from Ohio
well think of this chairman and thanks
to our witnesses and all the hard work
that you've been doing over the last
several months for not only the United
States but for individuals from around
the world greatly appreciated
doctor foul if I could start my
questions with you and I know that our
leader
mr. Walden had brought some of this up
would you further explain how an
infected individual develops antibodies
and how long those antibodies remain
effective in fighting off the virus and
are you seeing different levels of
antibodies and people who have been
infected and what that means in terms of
immunity thank you very much for that
question congressman Latta so we need to
start off by saying that we want to
assume you're dealing with a antibody
test that's been validated by the FDA or
by the NIH that's important because a
lot of the confusion out there there are
tests that are not validated but let's
assume you have a good test whenever the
body gets confronted with a virus and
recovers even when they don't recover
the body is stimulated to make
antibodies in general for viruses that
we have a lot of experience with those
antibodies serve to protect you against
exposure and infection after you're
exposed to the same virus so that's what
we call immunological memory and these
proteins block the virus the one thing
we do not know yet with kovat 19 is the
relationship between the type of
antibody because the best antibody is
called neutralizing antibody namely if
this were the virus and this is where
the virus binds to the cell the
neutralizing antibody blocks the virus
from binding to the cell there are
antibodies against other parts of the
virus that are called binding antibodies
they don't mean much so you got to make
sure you get the right antibody the
second thing is what we still don't know
is what the relationship between the
titer of the antibody is namely the the
the level of the antibody and the degree
of protection the third
thing we don't know is how long or what
the duration of that antibody is going
to be we're gonna find these things out
as we study these individuals over
months and a year or more
but remember we're only a few months
into this so a we know they make anybody
be it's likely that they're protected
for some period of time but we don't
know how long that's gonna be
so the question I always get asked which
is a subtext does that mean if you're
exposed and you have anybody that you're
protected likely you are but we don't
know how long you are protected all
right well thank you dr. Redmond or a
Redfield sitting when a vaccine or
treatment is developed
how will it be distributed to Americans
thank you for the question
this it's a critical issue that is
currently under discussion within the
team to look at what the appropriate
priority is I want to just comment that
it may be very dependent on what the
product is each of these vaccine
products that are currently being
developed may in fact have differential
utilization for different populations so
they're they're they're a serious
consideration to try to develop those
priorities and it's going to be
important to develop them dependent on
the product that they're going to be
applied to thank you doctor and thanks
very much for all your work and thanks
for taking my calls especially on Friday
nights and on Saturdays I appreciate it
the FDA provided an emergency use
authorization for Ramez of your do you
expect or envision the FDA to issue any
more EU A's for potential treatments in
the fall congressman for potential
therapies yes sir
right yeah yes sir so we are working
very closely with sponsors regarding the
development of therapeutics including
with operation
speed 131 clinical trials ongoing right
now I anticipate that we will receive
data regarding a several therapies in
the future
plasma being one of them are we just
discussed with Congress from almond
potentially also with some
anti-inflammatory agents as well as for
monoclonal antibodies those those are
being accelerated through the pipeline
men are potential therapeutics as well
as prophylaxis and moving forward again
can't prejudge the EU a process because
we have to see the data but I do
anticipate that we will be receiving
data thank you very much miss Sherman my
time is expired are you back thank you
next we have miss de guy from Colorado
thank you so much mr. chairman I want to
thank the panel and welcome all of you
many in front of my subcommittee the
oversight and investigation subcommittee
a number of times and just to let you
know that oh and I subcommittee is going
to be continuing its investigations both
about how we responded to this and where
we go in the future so you can expect to
hear from us I have some brief questions
for each witness and I'd like to start
with You Admiral Gerar the Chairman
talked his comments last week saying
that that saying the double testing
because when you do think we're going to
find more people and then again this the
president's case going up us because we
were testing far more than any of you
and ever expanded with smaller thing
we've further cases this is what he says
and he also said this morning that he
doesn't look about
so it's chairman aster profound dr. Rick
David started to test less I asked you
it's you learn now in charge of
overseeing the tests has the president
asked you to do fewer tests thank you
and
again I want to clarify that yes yes or
no won't work ever notice the president
yes neither the president nor anyone in
the administration has instructed or
suggested that we should do less testing
have said that to me and we are
proceeding in just the opposite we want
to do more talking of higher quality so
I want to ask you Admiral do you think
that it's a good or a bad idea to do
less testing so it will look like your
cases my purpose my purpose in leading
is to increase the number of testing the
only way that we will be able to
understand who has the disease who is
infected and can pass it and to do
appropriate contact tracing is to test
appropriately smartly in as many people
as we can thank you so much ouchy I
wanted to ask you seen some data the
last few days that that while cases are
going up in this country deaths are
going down and I've seen some reporting
in media that in part that's because
younger people who tend to not to die
from kovat are the ones being infected
should we see this as a positive sign or
should we still be worried I think it's
too early to make that kind of link
congresswoman let me explain deaths
always lagged considerably behind cases
you might remember at at the time that
New York was in their worst situation
where the deaths were going up and yet
the cases were starting to go down the
deaths only came down multiple weeks
later so you're seeing more cases now
while the deaths are going down the
concern is if those cases then infect
people who wind up getting sick and go
to the hospital it is conceivable you
may see the deaths going up so I think
it's too early too
because the deaths are going down big
question dr. patchy for you we've seen
eye and I think you and I have talked
about this most vaccines take years if
not decades to to be approved and and
approved approved efficacious and
sometimes we don't find a vaccine at all
I have two questions for you
number one do you believe that we will
find a vaccine for the corona virus and
number two do you still stand by the
prediction you gave us some months ago
that we could actually have a vaccine by
early 2021
I feel cautiously optimistic
congresswoman that we will be successful
in getting a vaccine there's never a
guarantee of that but the early data
that we're seeing regarding the
immunogenicity and the induction of good
responses makes me cautiously optimistic
always knowing that there's never a
guarantee you remember I told your
committee a few months ago that a
vaccine would be available from a year
to 18 months I said that in January of
2019 2020 a year from January is
December I still think there is a
reasonably good chance that by the very
beginning of 2021 that if we're going to
have a vaccine that we will have it by
then thank you very much doctor mr.
chairman are you back thank to
gentlewoman next we have mrs. Rogers
from Washington State
I hope I'm coming cathy McMorris Rogers
is here am I here you recognized for
five minutes
Thank You mr. chairman I want to thank
the chair and the ranking member for
holding this hearing and appreciate our
witnesses for testifying today kovat 19
is the challenge of the century as
others have said it's a health and
economic crisis of our lifetime we mourn
the deaths of over a hundred thousand
Americans and we must remember that
we're not out of the woods yet I want to
especially express my heartfelt
gratitude for the health care workers
the first responders the emergency and
essential workers who have been working
around the clock to fight this virus
save lives and keep our families safe as
our experts work tirelessly to develop a
vaccine and treatment I'm confident that
there's no country in the world who's
better equipped to lead for a medical
breakthrough than America we can't trust
China to lead and that's why the Trump
administration has created programs like
operation warp speed we're bringing
together the very best in the public and
private sector to develop
countermeasures that will fight the
virus we're leveraging the power of
artificial intelligence supercomputing
and machine learning to speed up
discoveries and enhance our knowledge
base of the virus in Washington State we
have top researchers as well as biotech
pharmaceutical innovators who continue
to be at the forefront of these
breakthroughs I look forward to learning
more and appreciate all of you being
here to understand what the
administration is continuing to do to
lead in the development of these tests
and treatments that American needs so
that we can usher in a new era of
innovation and health care cures to win
the future keep our families healthy and
save lives and to ensure our economy
booms again we must get this right
doctor foul Qi as you know edge events
maximize the effectiveness of vaccines
would you just explain a
little bit further what an adjuvant is
and are there any novel synthetic
adjuvants in the pipeline and if so how
will they play a role in the
administration's pursuit of a Copa 19
vaccine thank you very much for that
question congresswoman and adjuvant is a
product distinct from the vaccine itself
but when given in conjunction with the
vaccine it enhances the power of the
immune response so if you have a vaccine
that gives a level of response that here
when you get an adjuvant together with
it
you often boost it to a much higher
level we use adjuvant in several
vaccines the NIH has a major program in
the pursuit and development of novel
adjuvant of all different types and in
fact that's part of the program right
now to accelerate our vaccine
development capability so it's a good
question but it's a very important part
of what we do thank you thank you thank
you for that dr. Hahn as you know FDA's
decentralisation of diagnostic test
oversight has been very helpful in
expanding the availability of diagnostic
tests for koban 19 but is temporary has
this flex would you just speak to how
this flexibility has benefited the
general public and and how you think it
would be helpful in the future for
outbreaks or novel viruses thank you
very much Congress I'm gonna appreciate
the question as you pointed out the
flexibilities have allowed us to work
with test developers this has been
throughout the kovat pandemic with all
of our medical products a balance
between the oversight so that we have
tests that are valid reproducible
accurate but at the same time allow the
developers the ability to have the
freedom and develop those tests and
we've developed this partnership that I
think has been very fruitful moving
forward I particularly like it with
respect to the flexibility given the
states your state in particular which
has an excellent
public health laboratories as well as
University of Washington and New York
State's another example of this those
are the sort of things that we're
looking at now as we talk about how we
want to move forward that we could
potentially put in place on a permanent
basis to facilitate test development
hopefully we'll never be in a position
again where we have to develop tests
over such a short period of time like
we've remarkably done during this time
but we really do need to talk about how
these flexibilities could stimulate
innovation and development of tests
great well thank you all thank you all
for your leadership your commitment
during this time the long hours and I
especially appreciate the way that we're
looking forward to make sure that we are
prepared in the future of whatever we
may face thank you good to be with you
thank you now we go to mr. Doyle coming
to us from Pittsburgh
mr. Doyle is mr. Doran mr. chairman I
forgot to unmute thank you you hear me
now yes you recognized for five minutes
Thank You mr. chairman for holding this
hearing and the ranking member also it's
more witnesses for your service on
behalf of the American people this
committee has continued to conduct
oversight of the Trump administration
shortcomings related to procuring and
distributing personal protective
equipment or PPE when states and
hospitals were faced with critical
shortages of the PPE such as masks and
gowns
president Trump passed the buck and said
the federal government was quote not a
shipping clerk we saw the result of a
failure of leadership without a national
strategy states have had to fend for
themselves and even compete against each
other for critical supplies it's become
so desperate out there that one former
US disaster official referred to this
grambo is quote Florida the flies PPP
the addition at a recent hearing before
the oversight and investigation
subcommittee Michigan Governor Gretchen
Whitner testified quote the lack of
centralized coordination at the federal
level created a counterproductive
competition between the states and
federal government to secure limited
supplies driving up prices and
exacerbating existing shortages Admiral
Greer let me ask you do we have enough
PPE for every frontline worker who needs
it
whether they be health care workers
first responders or thousands of others
whose job puts them at risk for people
still having to reuse n95 masks for
example and if we don't have enough why
hasn't the administration in both the
EPA to greatly expand the manufacturing
of these supplies well thank you for the
question and I will do my best to answer
that Admiral pull-up check is certainly
running the supply chain with with also
dr. Cadillac from asper but being a
member of the unifor unified
coordination group at FEMA for the past
three months I'm pretty familiar with
this I think as Admiral plod
check testified before and I think we
all know is that there was an absolute
shortage of everything when this started
everyone in the world was looking for
the same supplies and we tried to manage
that both from increasing the supplies
and using the DPA multiple times for
example there were three investments DPA
title one for n 95 s 3m Honeywell and
Owens and minor to improve production we
estimate that that the country in the
fall if there were a co vid outbreak to
this degree would need about a hundred
and forty and 940 million and ninety
five s per month um we should have a
hundred and eighty million per month
being produced domestically by that time
this was not available when we started
in March the industry was not here this
was all offshored and I'll just say
cumulatively between March 1st and June
19th the government distributed or
enabled the commercial distribution
through the air bridge of a hundred and
sixty million and ninety-five mass six
hundred and thirty eight million
surgical and procedural mass 281 million
gowns and over 16 billion pairs of
gloves so this was really an enormous
effort we need to be better prepared
this all needs to be onshore we're
working with S&S 2.0 to have a 60 to 90
day supply we talked to governor's in
every state many of the states are also
doing their own supplies for 60 to 90
days so I'm confident moving from here
on as we ramped domestic manufacturing
that we're going to be in a much better
position than we were three months ago
Thank You Admiral dr. Hahn let me ask
you since the man for PPE increased this
spring we've seen many actors with
little previous experience in the supply
supply field entered the mark reports
have indicated that the summer selling
counterfeit or low quality products that
don't meet safety requirements are
unable to fulfill agreements what steps
is the FDA taking to ensure that
companies are not circumventing federal
oversight and injecting potentially
substandard PPE into the United States
market
Thank You congressman this is a really
important issue during the height of
this epidemic and the increased demand
we provided regulatory flexibility for
companies but insisted that they provide
certification often foreign FTAs if you
will certification that the PPE met the
requirements that that we we have in
place and that the foreign governments
had in place but we did something else
with respect to that and that is we also
partnered with CDC and NIOSH for example
within ninety five s to test to verify
that in fact that self certification
over the the validity of the efficacy of
the PP was in place and you've correctly
identified that for a variety of reasons
subsequent product that was shipped in
the country did not meet those
specifications we immediately took
action to make sure that those were off
of the market and continue to do that
and monitor it very closely Thank You
mr. chairman I see my time is expired I
yield back
thank you mr. Doyle next we have a mr.
Guthrie coming to us from Kentucky are
you muted do you want to unmute I
thought I did breaker three I apologize
hi I'm dr. Cobie 19 counterfeit testing
and I have a bill that would bring you
called the safeguarding therapeutics Act
that would ensure FDA has the authority
to destroy the counterfeit tests and
devices now follow up with a question
with this what I'm interested in what
the people that I talk to every day are
interested in is it's what's going on in
the future how we're going to protect
ourselves moving forward we need to
lessons learn from the past we need to
look forward and dr. Hahn kinda answered
on PA excuse me doctor I'm a murder
Aurra answered on the PPE kind of moving
forward but if I could just go with dr.
red and Phil dr. pouchy and then dr. hon
Anil talk about pool testing and how
that might be effective well the people
that I talk to what's it gonna look like
in March I'm excuse me what's gonna like
in August our kids going to be getting
back in school our nursing homes going
to be
that's what people are looking for so
dr. Reagan Phil I know we're gonna have
flu or I have co-ed
what's the testing gonna be like doctor
thought you want do we need to be
looking for and dr. Han full testing and
I'll just open it up for you three to
talk about what's it going to look like
in August and our kids going to be able
to go back to school thinking I'll start
with dr. red until Thank You congressman
I think first and foremost it's really
important that we continue to take this
time to continue to accelerate our
capacity to diagnose obviously readily
available timely test results build that
capacity for isolation contact tracing
and so self-quarantine that's
fundamental we're working hard to do
that as I mentioned in January we had
about 6,000 contact tracers in this
country the beginning of June it was up
to around 27 28 thousand to continue to
increase in my view towards a hundred
thousand we get that operationally
functional that's going to be critical
for what we're doing
secondly we do have to reinforce in the
American public the importance of the
social distancing interventions that
we've discussed particularly face
coverings six-feet distancing in
hand-washing I anticipate that the
states will begin to open up higher
education and and and k12 it's going to
be on a jurisdiction to jurisdiction
decision a CDC will be issuing issuing
additional guidance on this topic in the
days ahead
as we continue to try to work and open
up these particularly the school systems
how to open them up safely I will end
with nursing homes I think we've made an
enormous of progress in the long-term
care facilities enhancing infection
control admiral gerard may want to
comment about the commitment that he
made to provide all nursing homes
protective equipment for a period of
time and continuing I think to have
aggressive surveillance in the nursing
home
across this country where we've
recommended it all residents get tested
so that we can start with a clean
baseline of understanding where the
epidemic is I will just end with the
fact that although they only make up
point six percent of our population
nursing home residents have made up more
than 35 percent of our mortality let me
very briefly doctor in jail dr. Fauci
yeah let me briefly address the question
you asked about schools because we get
asked that all the time I think the
important thing to point out is that as
you well know we live in a very big
country that is certainly not a
uni-dimensional country it's very very
different whether you're in a New York
metropolitan area or Casper Wyoming so
when you're asking about schools you
have to say where are you talking about
because we have different regions
different states different cities towns
and counties so some counties may have
such a low level of infection if schools
can open in a way that's exactly like
normal others may be in a situation
where it isn't really bad where you want
to close the school but you might want
to make some modifications alterations
are scheduling things like morning after
noon one day or another day so it's up
to the local officials to evaluate where
you are in the particular region what
the recommendations that we really very
carefully put out about the guidance
opening schools so you don't want to
make one size fits all for the United
States you want to tailor it to the
degree of viral dynamics in the
particular location that you're talking
about so looking forward we can make
those decisions that's that's
unfortunate but obviously the reality
I'll submit a question for the record
for pool for pool sampling thank you
very much and I yield back
thank you mr. Guthrie sounded like there
was a monster that was going to envelop
you at some point there next we have
miss Schakowsky from Illinois
thank you Thank You mr. chairman and I
want to thank the witnesses I have to
disagree with you dr. Redfield I think
nowhere has the Trump administration's
come lack of leadership been more
apparent than in our nation's nursing
homes and long-term care facilities
where we've lost 50,000 residents and
workers took over 19 so let's review
some of the deadly failures you delayed
data collection on cases and deaths and
nursing homes you have not required
required States to conduct testing you
are you are not giving workers adequate
PPE and I agree with Congressman dwell
on that to protect themselves you are
allowing facilities to literally kick
residents out of out onto the street if
there's a more profitable Co good
patient to take their place
and since EMS administrator Verma who is
responsible for the safety of our
nursing home residents has declined
chairman colognes invitation to speak
let me refer them to dr. Redfield the
CDC website explains that your mission
is to save lives by from providing
health information that protects our
nation so why didn't you require nursing
homes to report any data on kovat 19
cases and deaths until May 4 months
after you may remember you told me about
the first case in Illinois January 30th
and two to report the case of
human-to-human transparent transfer oh
I'm July 4 on June 4th you testified
before the House Appropriations
Committee and apologized for CDC's
inadequate I quote response
to covert 19 race and ethnicity data yet
the same day CMS and CDC finally
published Kovac 19 data from nursing
homes and failed to include race and
ethnicity information so when when my
office asked CMS about the exclusion we
were told to ask the CDC so will you
promise to include race and ethnicity
information moving forward so that we
can identify the address the and address
the racial disparities in nursing home
kovat 19 cases Thank You congressman for
your question
first I want to stress that since the
early beginning of the pandemic we've
initially encouraged all nursing homes
to report the cases through their health
departments and through our national
healthcare safety network as of May if I
could just briefly interrupt on the word
encourage that I think is a problem that
there's the guidance there's been
encouragement but what about mandating
as I said that as of May 8th now it is a
requirement that this be reported in
through CDC as CMS has made that
required and we are working to make sure
this reporting is comprehensive to
include ethnic and racial data as well
as I would are put forth that we've
worked hard to really accelerate
training and Retraining of infection
control procedures in these nursing
homes to to try to mitigate the
situation that unfortunately we did
experience as you pointed out where the
nursing home residents have taken a high
burden of this initial outbreak we will
continue to work to get this reporting
this reporting is going to be forward
facing CDC before the the day
to CMS CMS will forward face it so
families can make decisions based on
their understanding of how different
nursing homes are performing we have
recommended that the nursing homes as
you mentioned that they screen all
residents and we've recommended that
they screen all workers in their seen
homes on a weekly basis because we do
believe this is an important area that
we have to do more as a nation to
protect infections let me just say this
kind of suggestion and recommend has
clearly not been enough I view this is
the view of many observers families
workers that there is a crisis in our
nursing homes that persists and that we
insist that the government or to help
and I yield back
Thank You mr. Cozzi mr. Olson of Texas
Thank You chairman pallone and leading
Republican member Greg Waltons for
having this very important hearing
welcome for expert witnesses y'all have
been the frontlines find the köppen 19
virus for about half a year now we
greatly appreciate all your efforts to
make our country safer and a special
howdy to a former Rice satellite myself
Commissioner Hogg
allows first of all all of you know that
Texas and Greater Houston have seen a
spike in covent 19 cases over the last
week our stays it stays through
reopening and the trend is not good the
dr. Tony Fauci of Houston of Texas dr.
Steve Peter Hotez put out tweet I quote
what he said if this trajectory persists
Houston will be the worst affected city
United States baby rival war see right
now in Brazil end quote
and that is damn scary the spike
in regions due to one County Harris K
which is the county the third largest
county in America in the county seat of
Harris County website Harris County in
Houston County city of Houston the
fourth largest seat mr. chair I like to
have a graphic for the record about the
spikes in Houston in Harris County and
Fort Bend County without objection so
ordered thank you
there's many factors or we have the
spike right now in Texas and in Houston
but it scares me the most is the
increase in infections cases people aged
20 to 39 the so-called youngsters last
week they're one third of the new cases
in my hometown of Sugarland in my own
County a four-bed in the Greater Houston
region this is because of their attitude
subtractive my former boss phil gramm's
said it best about these people how
they've coming view this crisis bang the
cove at 19 curve and ending the pandemic
is like going to heaven everyone wants
to go there but fewer and fewer want to
do the hard work to make it happen I
call this the bad attitude curve and dr.
Falchi if you work a for a day
how can change this bad attitude curve
and make these people address it to
issue for the threat it truly is
well congressman you bring up a very
good point one of them very perplexing
things about kovat 19 and I've as some
of you know have been dealing with viral
outbreaks for the last 40 years I've
never seen a single virus that is one
pathogen have arranged from 20 to 40
percent of the people have no symptoms
to some get mild symptoms to some get
symptoms enough to put them at home for
a few days some are in bed for
and have symptoms even after they
recover others go to the hospital some
require of oxygen some require intensive
care
some get intubated and some die so you
have a situation that is very confusing
to people because some people think it's
trivial it doesn't bother me who cares
and that's one of the reasons why what
we do have is a lack of appreciation
that you have a dual responsibility you
have a responsibility to yourself
because I think thinking that young
people have no deleterious consequences
is not true we're seeing more and more
complications and young people but even
though the majority the overwhelming
majority of them do well but you can't
forget is that if you get infected and
spread the infection even though you do
not get sick you are part of the process
of the dynamics of an outbreak and what
you might be propagating inadvertently
perhaps innocently is infecting someone
who then infects someone who then is
someone who's vulnerable that could be
your grandmother your grandfather your
sick uncle who whom have you who winds
up dying so it's a very difficult
messaging when people say I'm young I'm
healthy who cares you should care not
only for yourself but for the impact you
might have on the dynamics of the
outbreak the bad attitude about I have a
question for the record for dr. Redfield
about hurricane evacuation of Cova 19
people from nursing homes I yield back
thank you very much thank you mr. Olsen
next we go to mr. Butterfield from North
Carolina
you might have to unmute GK Thank You
mr. chairman I make enough to be able to
do it yes
but thank you mr. chairman and thank you
to all of our witnesses today mr.
chairman in response to cope at 19
Congress has appropriated significant
funding through the cares Act and it
looks like some of that money is finally
getting into underserved communities the
Congressional Black Caucus health brain
trust led by congresswoman Robin Kelly
has met with some all of you and and
we've written you on to urge funding for
minority institutions and communities to
fight the pandemic an admiral secretary
you announced this morning that HHS has
formed a partnership with the Morehouse
School of Medicine that's good a
partnership to coordinate a strategic
network of organizations to deliver
Cobra 19 related information to minority
communities hardest hit by the pandemic
does the Morehouse funding give the
Medical School discretion to engage in
aggressive contact tracing and other
testing and education we need more than
information what is their mandate so
thank you for that question sir the the
intent of this award is really not to
empower more house to physically do
contact tracing themselves but to be a
lead institution to build partnerships
throughout the nation so that public
health organizations etc can use the
well over eleven billion dollars at the
CDC sent out so we are not funding
Morehouse to be the boots on the ground
we're funding them to be the brains
behind the operation to really extend
our network throughout the they be happy
to get into this but they they assembled
really a remarkable group of partners
using digital technologies all types of
network technologies they have very
broad discretion this is out of my
office
what I want to do I want to do is make
sure that the underserved get the
information get testing usually doctor
felt you the Washington Post reported
this morning that Arizona is seeing a
troubling spike the state of Arizona and
as we all know President Trump is in
Phoenix today for a campaign rally and
dreams city church and I suspect he will
not be wearing a mask I know that will
disappoint you it will certainly
disappoint me the Washington Post also
reported that Arizona got its positive
rate down to seven percent but now it's
up to twenty percent after eighty three
week rise in my state of North Carolina
we got it down to seven percent in now
in North Carolina it's up to ten percent
so ten percent in North Carolina up from
seven and twenty percent in Arizona what
is the administration specifically doing
to slow the spread in states like
Arizona and North Carolina that are
seeing a rise it can't it just can't be
explained away by more testing well
congressman the percentages that you're
speaking of are clearly indication that
there are additional infections that are
responsible for those increases because
when you get an increase in the
percentage of your tests that are
positive that's an indication that you
do have additional infections so one of
the issues that we spoken about that's
very clear is that when you have those
kinds of increases you must implement on
the ground as effectively as possible
the manpower the system the tests to do
identification isolation and contact
tracing to try and blunt that surge of
cases in the two states that you're
speaking of hopefully that will be
successful in the blunting of those
cases because if not then you have the
danger of having a gradual insidious
increase in community spread which will
be much more difficult to contain as the
community
spread amplifies itself but it just
seems to me in closing I'm dr. Falchi
and you don't need to respond to this
but it seems to me that the president
seems to think that Kovac is over and he
can just push it all to the states on
the data that's coming out of the state
shows the necessity the absolute
necessity for a national strategy
because while the bars may seem
contained in some areas it is
conceivable that we can see a resurgence
everywhere this frightens me and should
frighten the American people Thank You
mr. chairman I yield back
Thank You mr. Butterfield so now dr.
Burgess is here and we recognize him for
five minutes
Thank You mr. chairman in fact I was
with you virtually earlier so I heard
all the discussion back and forth and I
would ask you that as a consent to my
opening statement be made part of the
record and I do want to thank our
panelist for being here today outside of
a tiny little bit that we tacked on to a
budget hearing on February 27th we
really have not heard from this group
enough in in this committee and
certainly the health subcommittee so I
want to thank you for it really needs to
be here today and testify I'd also
observe that we're about the one-year
anniversary of the passage and signing
of the pandemic all hazard preparedness
Act we had a wonderful opportunity in
January February perhaps early March of
this year to do some real-time
introspection as to whether or not that
bill had gotten things right did we do
what we wasn't performing as intended it
wasn't going as expected and for
whatever reason we chose to talk about
flavored tobacco horse racing and ticket
stubs instead so we can be critical of
the administration mr. Shermer but this
committee this committee bears some of
that responsibility as well since we've
been talking about community spread and
increase in community spread I also dr.
Falchi been talking to some of my
counterparts physicians in the Lower Rio
Grande Valley and
and in that part near the border of
Mexico community spread has been
apparently significant over the last
week to ten days I guess the question I
would have for you and and for Admiral's
you are is since we recognize community
spread is increasing and we recognize
that there still going to be the
vulnerabilities of congregate living
facilities what are we doing to make
certain that the appropriate amount of
personal protective equipment is
available to our congregate living
facilities extended care facilities and
nursing homes not just in the valley but
any any place where we see this
community spread increasing so thank you
dr. Burgess good to see you again see
you again I am familiar with the PPE
situation from my work on the ucg at
FEMA and I think you I think you know
that it was decided by the ucg very
early that when we were able to secure
the PPE we would send directly to every
and we're sending PPE directly to 15,000
I believe the number is 400 narcing
homes and the numbers are really
staggering millions of face shields
masks 13 million pairs of gloves already
there so that's being distributed right
now and they're gonna be multiple
tranches of that again Admiral pull-up
Chuck is running this through the supply
chain task force I've got all the swabs
and all the tests he runs the PPE and we
interact a lot so that's going to be
going all the way through August and
September through all 15,400 nursing
homes with multiple shipments of that do
you agree that that is on the immediate
horizon ahead that's one of the big
vulnerabilities community spray is
increasing in some places but we also
know we've got areas or this congregate
living people with with multiple risk
factors so I think is has maybe been
said by the colleagues we are clearly
seeing community spread in a number of
areas if you look at counties
I think dr. Burks detailed yesterday
they're about a hundred and ten counties
of real concern throughout well I guess
I've morph used me for interrupting but
my time is short I guess what I'm really
asking us are we preparing and do our
administrators and executives in nursing
facilities nursing home facilities know
how to access the vast amounts of
personal protective equipment that's
being made available through air bridge
and through the work you've done because
if we don't get it to the end-user then
it's a vulnerability and it will affect
all of us very briefly because I know
the time I'm gonna say the answer is yes
because we decided to ship door-to-door
because we couldn't necessarily rely on
the state distribution systems
you know because you just can't get that
deep so the only way to do it is get the
address and ship it and then secondly
the testing regimens that are now
mandated through CMS recommended by CDC
are pretty excellent right every nursing
home resident gets tested every worker
gets tested every week this is a very
robust testing regimen that we think is
gonna put high protection certainly has
been in Texas dr. Redfield in just a
very brief amount of time I have
remaining just ask you a question we
heard some things and of course people
are concerned about about China the
impact that China has had on our ability
to fight this virus are there people
working in the CDC in Atlanta who are
Chinese nationalists do you have such
people on loan from from Chinese labs in
the in the agency well a CDC does have
an office CDC has an office in Beijing
that is right next to the China CDC and
we work collaboratively on a series of
things particularly respiratory viruses
and particularly influenza we haven't
been brought in into the overall Chinese
investigation of this current
coronavirus epidemic something I
requested back in January 3rd and then
formally on January 6 all right I want
to be helpful to you on that so I will
follow up with you and
I have some ideas or some other things
that we might think about as well but I
think that's a critical part of our
discussion going forward and being
prepared into the future I think thank
you I'll take two panels
thank you dr. Burgess next we go to miss
Matsui in California they have to unmute
it I have you know Thank You mr.
chairman I want to also thank mrs. for
today 24/7 we really appreciate it now
why a lot of our questions today have
focused on how we in the midst of this
pendant a I like to focus my questions
on the future and how we are preparing
for the coming weeks and months and the
possibility of another dramatic surge in
cases of a second wave this fall
particularly between flip season refugee
it's nice to see you there you have said
that we are still in the wave and I
understand that is difficult to pick
what a second-- way would look like
while we're still seeing high counts
case counts and deaths currently however
we must effectively prepare our
communities our health care workforce
and constituents for what could come as
we make decisions about returning to
work going to school and trying to
readjust to what we considered somewhat
normal life doctor foul Qi I want you to
put your in a prognosticator cap on
right now what are the projected
infection mortality rates for the second
half of 2020 and for early 2021 thank
you for the question congresswoman it is
really impossible to give any projection
about what the fatality rate or case
rates are going to be it's going to
depend on so many factors I think you
alluded to that in the beginning of your
question when people talk about second
waves and I have said multiple times
publicly that we are still in the middle
of the first wave so before you start
talking about what a second wave is what
we'd like to do is to get this outbreak
under control over the next couple of
months so that when we enter into the
fall early late and then early winter
that we have such a low baseline that
when you do have the inevitable
situation of cases appearing as you try
to gradually reopen the country which
we're all trying to do to varying
degrees depending upon what state city
town or County you're in that if you get
a level that's very low when you get new
cases you can contain and contain means
identify isolate and contact trace
rather than have such a high level that
when you get increases you have to
mitigate right from the beginning so
that really as you can imagine
complicates the situation and makes it
impossible to predict what the case or
fatality rate is going to be until you
know where you are do you get down to
baseline and if so can you keep it there
as you enter into the complicating
situation that will inevitably occur
when we get into the winter and
inevitably we will have us flu season
and that's the reason why we have saying
all of us why it's so important to
really get as many people vaccinated
with influenza as you possibly can so
that you can at least take off the table
for many people one of the confounding
issues that we're going to face this
winter of to respiratory borne
infections simultaneously confounding
each other now why would you say doctor
about you understanding that we don't
know yet but we have a sense that we are
gonna have a second wave
what should the public knows well they
can be prepared for this and what as a
country can we all do to reduce the
potential for this second wave somehow
another to manage it because I think
that all of us believe something is
going to be happening
and we need to know what we can do now
thank you for that the second part of
the question there are a lot of things
that can be done we know what the
failings were early on a lack of enough
PPE a lack of enough and 95s hospital
bed issues ventilated issues all that is
right now being stored up in the
strategic national stockpile in
preparation for what we hope never
occurs but which very well might occur
so it's the preparation also as Admiral
Dryad mentioned as we go into the fall
we likely will we have the capability of
doing 40 to 50 million tests per month
which means we can get a much better
grasp of what the situation is of the
dynamics of virus in the community so
hopefully we will be much better
prepared if in fact we do get this
second surge and we were months ago
anyway thank you very much and I yield I
thank the gentlewoman next we moved to
mr. McKinley Thank You mr. chairman I'm
gonna direct my first question to dr.
Falchi the New York Times CNN a
Washington Post have relentlessly
criticized president Trump's response
over 19 calling it a failure you heard
today a lack of leadership but wait you
know nearly 750,000 people have God in
America from drug overdose and we still
don't have a solution aids has killed
over 700,000 people in America and we
don't have a cure for that either look
the first case of copán was diagnosed in
America just a hundred and 55 days ago
and according to testimony we had
earlier this this spring the
pharmaceutical experts say they that we
could have a treatment by fall and a
vaccine by date by January keeping in
mind it took almost 10
years to come up with a vaccine for the
influenza and four years for mumps
nevertheless the media and the left
simply can't help but criticize
President Trump so my question to you is
do you think do you think the President
Trump is being treated judged fairly
oh actually that's an unfair question
because you're asking me to pass
judgment on the press's treating of the
President of the United States
that's mean it may be unfair but you've
had you've know numerous times you've
commented and critici-- contradicted
what the president says so I do you
think he's being judged fairly well it
depends on what you mean I mean I work
in the White House and I believe that
everyone there is doing everything they
possibly can thank you to do what they
need to do doctor you said it's late and
I've got a newspaper article that that
as late as March 31st there was no
consensus on wearing masks that the and
the President as you know relies on your
ear expertise do you now regret not
advising people more forcefully to wear
masks earlier okay we're gonna play that
game let me explain to you what happened
back then should be a yes or no no
there's more than a yes or no by the
tone of your question I don't regret
that because let me explain to you what
happened at that time there was a
paucity of equipment that our health
care providers needed who put themselves
daily in harm's way of taking care of
people who are ill we did not want to
divert masks and PPE away from them to
be used by the people okay now that we
have enough weakly recommend I've got
two more questions so thank you for that
dart frezzer you said dr. Redfield I'm
gonna be directing this to you
nursing-homes as you we've talked about
here earlier make up nearly 90 or 40% of
all the Cova deaths and the CDC issued
guidance on
protocol for these facilities yet states
like Michigan New York New Jersey and
California apparently apparently
disregarded that guidance to dr.
Redfield do you think the decisions of
these governors led done necessary
deaths in these nursing homes thank you
for your question I think the the
critical issue here is two things one
our guidance is just that guidance to
areas that we could impact the nursing
homes particularly in the infection
control working together with CMS very
aggressively early on after the Seattle
outbreak was recognized in that nursing
home
really reach annulled energy into
looking at the effectiveness of
infection control in those nursing homes
then restricted visitors to make do you
think that the decisions led to
unnecessary deaths by not by allowing
infected
residents to come back into the nursing
home I think again all of these
decisions that have been made in the
early days are subject to to hindsight
we gave clear guidance and how people
should be handled if they come into
these nursing homes okay kid
now the third question back again to you
dr. Redfield we know in the foreseeable
future that we're not going to have a
zero risk of transmission we're not
going to get to that but it's so if we
want our economy to recover we know our
schools have to reopen so going back to
the school question in addition to
tracing distancing we're in mast what
rate of infection is needed in your mom
and your mindset for children to go back
to school what's the rate of infection
1% yeah I'm not prepared to give you
that definitive answer I am superior to
say that one of the most important
things we need to look at is not the
number of infections but the
consequences of these
infections and there's two really big
consequences one is hospital
hospitalization and mortality and the
other is our economy right and I think
we're clearly seen that in many parts of
our nation that one can open our economy
safely but it is going to require more
vigilance than some of us see right now
with the social distancing we're going
to continue to try to emphasize the
importance of social distancing facemask
and hand washing as we continue to do it
it's my expectations that many
jurisdictions will be opening schools
we're going to try to give the guidance
to help them do it safely I think you're
right as dr. Fauci alluded to before it
is going to be influenced by the
kinetics of the outbreak in the
jurisdiction at the time I'm not right
prepared to give you that number but I
think we're gonna see progressive
jurisdictions move to open schools in
the fall you'll Beck matanza we now go
to miss castor the gentlewoman from
Florida
I'd ask everybody to unmute before they
begin great thank you so much thank you
to our witnesses today when you compare
the number of confirmed cases and the
number of deaths in the United States
with countries across the globe it's
really shocking and and it's it makes me
angry and makes me sad at the same time
we have 2.3 million confirmed cases we
have just over 120 thousand Americans
who have lost their lives just in a few
months time and it appears that other
countries have done a better job of
controlling the spread they've done a
better job on testing and tracing every
advantage that the United States of
America has with our scientists our
public health experts something has gone
wrong here and I think it starts at the
top I think the president's behavior and
comments have undermined our public
health professionals every step of the
way dr. Wrenn pill I'd like to know how
often do you interact with the President
and talk to him about public health with
guidelines and and bringing all of your
expertise to bear how often do interact
with the president
well I have regular interactions with as
part of the White House Task Force as a
member to it and participate in each and
every one of the task force meetings and
as relates to my interactions directly
with the president I that I'm gonna keep
those between myself and the president
well you know every time the president
contradicts scientists every time he
contradicts our public health experts
whether wearing a mask or mass
gatherings or drinking bleach or taking
a hydrochloric when it costs lives and I
agree with my colleagues that we really
expect you to be more outspoken when it
comes to these public health advisories
it will cost lives it has cost lives and
but not to change up change direction
now for dr. pouchy
you know Floridians are very concerned
with the latest spike in cases the
Florida Department of Health announced
just a little while ago we've got
another 3,300 cases and 64 deaths just
since what was announced yesterday 25%
of the total cases in Florida have been
confirmed in just the past 10 days and
we have a positivity rate of now up to
13% in the past week so what message do
you have for the state of Florida and
other hotspots across the country as we
we have so many more young people who
feel invincible that are are testing
positive and and our economy is is
opened up what is your advice to
Floridians and others and hotspots you
know my advice to the Floridians is the
advice I would give to anyone and
everyone to follow the guidelines that
we have very carefully thought out and
put out and how one can reopen or open
America again and that is to stay within
the framework of the particular phase of
reopening you're in and to not throw
caution to the wind I think what happens
related to the comment I made a little
while
go about the confusion there must be
particularly among young people who have
a pent-up urge to go out which is
understandable but what they need to
appreciate is that they are part of a
process of the dynamics of an outbreak
and although they themselves may
perceive that they're at very low risk
for something that would be deleterious
to them by propagating the process of
the outbreak they may be indirectly are
hurting people by infecting someone who
then infects someone who then infects
someone who's vulnerable so they need to
understand that if we could get that
message across that it's not an
all-or-none phenomenon getting back to
normality is going to be a gradual
step-by-step process and not throwing
caution to the wind
what about and and what about masks for
young people there's a lot of you know
they look at national leaders who are
not muddling your advice and your
behavior what do you say because you're
a trusted scientist and an expert what
do you say directly about wearing masks
and mass gathering I'll be very
and I'll say it yet again that you
should not congregate in crowds you
should keep distance and even though
many people for a variety of reasons do
not listen to the not suggestion but
plea to not congregate in crowds some
people are going to do that anyway if
you do please wear a mask and as you
wear a mask and you're in a situation
where you're getting animated in a
demonstration or in a rally or wherever
you are
avoid as best as possible the urge to
pull your mask down and shout so plan a
don't go in a crowd plan B if you do
make sure you wear a mask thank you
thank you dr. pouchy go back next we go
to mr. Kissinger in Illinois and well
thank you mr. chairman
I'm unmuted Thank You mr. chairman and
thank you to all the guests for being
here it's a weird time and very
important so thank you I think you know
one of the discussions is this
communication is important so whether
it's between federal government state
governments local governments nonprofits
businesses but also international
governments and I think we need a lot
more information eventually on what the
Chinese Communist Party knew what they
withheld and what real impact they had
and what forward to that being more more
investigated we've all seen the stories
about people who are testing positive
for the virus and they show no symptoms
at all and in some cases it was able to
spread through entire communities of
people without ever knowing that they've
been infected
so dr. Fauci let me ask you given the
significant rate of these a somatic
asymptomatic infections how can antibody
test improve our understanding of the
transmission of kovin 19 and to help
identify populations at risk well one of
the things that we need to do and I
think that's very important and it
related to a previous question
about getting the kinds of surveillance
studies that allow you to get a much
better handle on a the real percentage
of asymptomatic carriers be the rate at
which they infect others and a variety
of other things I mean things that are
really important questions we learned
interestingly actually to my surprise
congressman that when you look at
asymptomatic individuals and people who
are symptomatic the level of virus and
their nasopharynx is is is almost the
same which is almost counterintuitive
but it is it is a fact which tells you
that the danger of transmissibility is
such that it is very important to
understand the penetrance of on a
symptomatic infected people and when you
do get them you need to identify them
isolate and contact tracing and
questions that were asked I don't know
an hour or so ago to the testing issue
we need to do much much more
surveillance testing and so the 40 to 50
million tests per month that would be
available as we get into the late summer
and early fall are gonna be able to ask
some of the questions your appropriately
asking Bret and I I just wanted to if I
could just build on that for a second
the 40 to 50 million test
I said assumes no advances in technology
and that's not even including pooling I
do say pooling because the FDA just put
up standards for validating pooling so
we would expect based on preliminary
data we have that on many tests we can
at least pull 5 to 1 and maybe up to 10
to 1 so when you do that math that I
think will be validated very quickly by
academic institutions and by large
organizations that number of 50 million
is going to go up by fivefold at least
per month great thank you and that's
what's amazing is frankly American
ingenuity when we put our minds to it
and seeing the advances and hopefully
when we get to a vaccine so at the
beginning of the pandemic both my wife
and I actually experienced what we
thought were symptoms of kovin
and we recently decided that we'd go and
get an antibody test I had that done and
I found out that I was actually negative
for the antibody so dr. Redfield in your
testimony you stated that at this point
we don't know whether the presence of
antibodies provides immunity to the
virus so with this in mind how does the
antibody testing help if we don't know
if it provides immunity to the virus and
what are the benefits of an antibody
test from an individual patient
perspective thank you very much for the
question congressman I think right now
at this stage I think important at the
individual patient level we don't know
what it means particularly in terms of
immunity as dr. Fauci said earlier what
it does mean again assuming it's a
reliable approved FDA test that you've
been infected in the past we don't know
though what that means in terms of
immunity its value to us at CDC is it's
for surveillance advantage right now
we've continued to do surveillance
throughout the United States through a
variety of different systemic
collections we're doing and it allows us
to see what the full extent of the
infection right now the data at a
national level suggest that for every
documented infection that we have as a
case report there's actually about ten
other individuals that actually had been
infected that data will continue to be
refined as we continue to expand our
antibody testing but I really think it's
major role right now is an important
surveillance tool thank you and I'll
just add another question I'll submit it
for the record about this virus lasting
on surfaces but with that I'll yield
back thank you thank you and I thank
remind everyone that you can submit
questions for the record to the to the
task force in the witnesses and that all
opening statements will be entered into
the record
so next we go to mr. sarbanes from
Maryland Thank You mr. chairman can you
hear me we can terrific I want to thank
the panel last month the Trump
administration announced the launch of
Operation warp speed to support rapid
research and development of Cove
vaccines therapeutics diagnostics and so
forth it's a project that's supposed to
coordinate efforts across the federal
government and engaged the private
sector including at least five
pharmaceutical companies that are
developing vaccines so I'm trying to
understand a little bit better how that
works first off there's been some
concerns raised about the venture
including potential conflicts among its
leadership conflicts of interest
dr. Falchi you've had decades of
experience leading public/private
partnerships with pharmaceutical company
to develop vaccines transparency is
important is it not in these
collaborations thank you for the
question
operation warp speed is a endeavor that
is a Department of Defense HHS led by
the secretary Esper and secretary azof
to try and get Diagnostics therapeutics
and vaccines done in a way that is
coordinated with the maximum speed
possible without sacrificing scientific
integrity it's divided up into three
groups the leader of this is Muntz F
Salah we a person with great experience
in industry as well as general Poorna
who is an army general who's very well
versed and very experienced in supply
chain of processes of getting vaccines
when we do get it to be produced to the
level that is needed as well as to be
distributed equitably throughout our
society so it's a let me jump in because
I want to - dr. Hahn I understand that a
senior FDA officials initially tapped
lead the vaccine development under
Operation warp-speed but then left the
project out of concerns political
pressures to approve vaccines
I assume you agree that the role FDA
plays in this has to be one that's not
impacted by political pressure and that
your agency is ready to adopt the
highest standards and approving any
vaccine that's developed under this
initiative
Connor s'en thank you for the question
your point is very well taken and I can
assure you that we will retain our
regulatory independence we will use the
designs and data that come to us and we
will use our high standards to assess
the safety and efficacy of a vaccine we
have world-class experts who will
continue to maintain that one point I do
want to make clear sir is that we drew a
very bright line between operation war
speed and all of our sponsors we do not
engage in decision-making neither I nor
dr. marks nor dr. Cavett Sony with
respect to those decisions we provide
technical assistance
as we do to all sponsors but we've made
it clear that we do not participate in
those decisions because we absolutely
must maintain regulatory independence
and make the right decision for the
American people based upon science and
data document again I'm trying to
understand the sort of the boundaries or
reach of the operation warp-speed effort
so my initial sense is that it was
focused on these five selected companies
that are pursuing vaccine candidates I'm
not entirely clear maybe that's not
right but I'm not entirely clear on what
this means for vaccine exploration
development beyond that for instance
I've been reading just over the last
week or ten days or so about this oral
polio vaccine opportunity maybe that has
promised maybe it doesn't but some
inquiry there I guess may be warranted
is that I'd like to get the panel's
perspective on whether you consider
those kinds of inquiry outside of
operation work speed or is that this
operation works to be broad enough to
accommodate those kinds of things in
addition to whatever is happening with
the five companies and sort of from
where your different agencies sit what's
your perspective and understanding of
that so let me just I guess go down the
line dr. Redfield when we start with you
and then dr. P and I guess Commissioner
Hahn would be the other one I will get
brief responses gentlemen because that
his time is up the only thing I would
say is it's intriguing in terms of the
potential of what we call viral
interference with these live virus
vaccines whether it's polio or measles
that they may impact another RNA virus
from being able to establish infection
infection so really that's the
hypothetical I think it's it's
intriguing not for just this pathogen
for other RNA viruses yeah very quickly
I think your question was is there room
for other other virus other vaccines the
answer is yes through multiple
mechanisms anything is on the table it
could be
through Operation Wharf speed it could
be through a number of mechanisms that
we have in our research institution at
NIH so I can understand your concern but
the doors are not closed to other
candidates you could be assured of that
sir I understand from FDA's perspective
we absolutely the doors are open there
as well we're working with multiple
different sponsors pharmaceutical
companies as well as operation
warp-speed
we will look at all data that comes
across the door we'll provide technical
assistance to all who want to develop a
vaccine and therapeutics thank you
Thank You mr. Griffith thank you very
much mr. chairman i greatly appreciate
dr. fanny and then dr. Redfield I'm
gonna push you a little bit on the spot
because I won't talk about schools and
as you might imagine a lot of
constituents are very concerned about
what's happening in the schools and dr.
patchy you earlier made some statements
which led me to believe that you believe
that not only nationally but even within
the state the size of Virginia we
probably ought to be looking regionally
and and maybe even locally as to how we
do it and and have it go forward do you
did I understand that correctly
understood me correctly congressman and
that's the point I want to make because
it's really a source of confusion it's
not one size fits all I think you have
to look at it at the local level the
county level of a regional level the
city level the state level so we often
say in America should you or should you
not be open I mean that's almost the non
question because we're such a large
country and so heterogeneous and such a
range of involvement of this virus in
different parts of the country and dr.
Redfield I'll move to you because in the
Commonwealth of Virginia they often are
citing and for various things related to
schools and others they cite the CDC do
you agree with dr. fetching his
assessment yes it needs to be a very
targeted jurisdictional decision and and
I greatly appreciate that because my
district is four hours from DC even
though people often think I'm right next
door and then the district stretches
from the very edge of it which is four
hours away another four and a half hours
so that it ends up going further west
than Detroit Michigan in the district
just my district is larger than the
state of New Jersey
so even within the district we may need
to have some additional regional
approaches would you all agree with that
yes and and dr. Petch indicates that
that as well
all right Commissioner Han in a
statement on March 30th 2020 you
recognized the importance of
facilitating access to viral samples in
order to speed up the development of
tests you noted that in the future
making virus samples available earlier
to commercial developers will be crucial
to deploying tests quickly this
certainly will not be the last time we
face rapidly spreading novel virus
strain how can the process for obtaining
viral samples especially inactivated
viral samples be improved in the future
for quicker access congressman thank you
for that question and I think that is
one of the lessons learned from this
situation with köppen 19 is that access
to those samples is very important we
would work with NIH with academics with
the CDC to make sure that those are
available and just to make a point we
for serology tests have made a reference
panel now available to developers to
actually facilitate that that's an
example of what u.s. government FDA NIH
and CDC could do I thank you and and I
apologize Admiral Jerome did I say it
close to correct or that's good enough
all right earlier this year you informed
this committee that enough testing
supplies would be distributed so that
the states could test the recommended 2%
of their populations per month yet
according to Johns Hopkins corona virus
testing trend tracking Center data only
about 20% of the states are testing the
recommended 2 percent of their
population per month while another 20
percent are testing less than 1 percent
of their population per month as the
administration been distributing
supplies to States and if so why do you
believe some states that have testing
supplies are not testing more of their
population so thank you for that again
before the full state plans were just
received and this was part of the PPP
funding that we've reviewed and we've
reviewed them extensively with the CDC
we set preliminary targets for every
stage by phone calls with every single
state every single state health officer
epidemiologist overall in May the target
was about twelve point nine million
tests throughout the country and about
twelve million were done this is really
very good considering many of the states
tried to do three or four times as many
tests as they done cumulatively during
that time you think we're on track I
think we're really on tracked right now
it looks very good some states have
underperformed especially in May most of
them have improved their performance in
June and our preliminary review of all
the state plans the great majority of
them I mean the overwhelming majority
were very good - excellent
so everyone is getting the message and I
look forward to that I thank you and dr.
fat chip and come back to you when we
first started this you know we we knew
it was going to be tough and then we're
probably never going to get rid of this
particular virus but we talked about
bending the curve and making sure our
hospitals were ready based on your
comments on PPE and face masks and so
forth I believe that you think that
we're probably ready maybe not perfect
but we're ready and have we not bent the
curve understand it's not over it's not
gonna be over anytime soon we've got to
wear our masks and do what we're
supposed to but don't you think we've
bent the curve and that our hospitals
are now ready your mic on sorry sir
yes we've been through a terrible ordeal
we've learned a lot the pre paratus now
is clearly logarithmically different
than it was in the beginning and so
we've bent the curve in our Hospital
already I yield back
thank you next we go to mr. McNerney
coming from California would you on you
Thank You chairman and I think the
witnesses for your work and your experts
expertise we can hear you okay thank you
um so I'm deeply concerned by president
Rene at the United States relationship
with the organization and I'm not alone
in this concern of the American Medical
Association has the president's move a
senseless action that will have
significant harmful repercussions
now harpie on this perilous moment it
appears that the president is not acting
on sound public guidance but it is
instead scapegoating the whu-oh the
deflect from his administration's
failure in responding to the koban 19
and ethic according to a report in
Vanity Fair key US agencies that work
with the whu-oh on critical public
health programs were not consulted or
asked for an impact analysis before the
president's decision to withdraw dr.
Hatake were you consulted about the
potential public health impact of the
United States was dry from the wao
and if so what were you for
recommendations Jerry I apologize we
said we were going to take a break at
1:30 so everyone could go to the
restroom or whatever for 15 minutes and
dr. fat she had to step out so I'm gonna
ask you to start over again we'll take a
15-minute break so everybody can use the
restrooms and then we'll start again
with Jerr and you'll have to repeat your
questions this committee stands
adjourned for 15 minutes
people are coming it's not really a cute
type of restaurant but yes there there's
a waitlist we think our business will
remain stable due to the situation where
everyone in Hong Kong is here and
normally there's a slowdown in the
summer but everyone will be in Hong Kong
this summer so on the one hand we don't
have people coming into Hong Kong but
all we also don't have people going out
of Hong Kong
but honestly our business is not bad you
know we had me committed to this project
for a long time our investment was about
3 million u.s. dollars some of the
measures that we've taken are of all our
team members wearing masks during
service frequent hand washing thinking
of temperatures of anyone enters the
premises I know it seems like we're
aware of your company but I think the
values are what's important
we put taking care of people first
safety comes first
there's always room to do things you
know a lot of these small restaurants
are quite inexpensive maybe they need to
charge a little bit more for the short
term maybe people will be happy to pay
more to feel that that they're safe
we've also received tremendous support
from our unity of guests we've had some
initiatives to raise money for for
people to work in our company and
whatnot and we've done things like sell
gift certificate you know there were
times where people were staying at home
and foreign tiing and they said we want
to support you we can't come out but we
want to buy something
[Music]
you told me the beginning of the year
I'd be dressing mannequins and I
wouldn't believed you but I think it's
had a great reaction
[Music]